Congressman Jim Jordan is a Republican
representing Ohio right in the middle of
all this and he joins us tonight
congressman thanks a lot for coming on
so the obvious question as we have the
final debate over the wall during the
final hours that Republican congressman
yeah why now why two years later well
I'll be you're right we should have done
it earlier we're Center done in March on
the big spending bill we told American
people we would then we said no no we're
going to do it in September didn't do it
then on that spending bill then we said
we'll do it on December 7 no we didn't
do then and then we said we'll do it on
December 21st we did it tonight in the
house I mean just a few minutes ago it
passed even though last week in the Oval
Office Nancy Pelosi said the house can't
get the votes to pass a border security
wall funding for a border security wall
we just did a few minutes ago got 217
votes I think that Democrats had 185 so
we just passed it in the house that's
step one and now goes back to the Senate
and we'll see what happens from there
but we need to stand firm one this is
because as as you said as the president
said this is a central promise we made
the voters in 2016 this is our last best
chance to do what everyone knows is just
good common sense everyone but Democrats
I should say knows good common sense I
think it's fair for the rest of us to
press a little deeper and ask well why
didn't it happen I mean your absolute
right it should have happened you
probably would have preferred it had
happened earlier when we push for it to
happen earlier yes right right I
remember but it didn't and that means
that people prevented it from happening
obviously speaker Ryan was one of them
who else just for the rest of us keeps
well it look it's always easier I mean
to do something that really counts it
has lasting value lasting meaning it's
never easy so what is worth a sure what
exactly so anything worth doing is
always difficult but Congress always has
a way of trying to take the least
resistant route and do the easy thing so
that's why it happened I think most of I
mean look and I know you were for it but
the tax bill was definitely hard there
was a lot of opposition to it and the
leadership just decided we're getting
this done that's not something that
Trump ran on or there was broad public
support for it but they wanted it and
they got it done and they worked really
hard came on the show made the case for
it did you read that with the wall and
why I just wanna think it's fair to know
since you're on the inside we're not who
prevented that well I don't know any
what prevented it but I think the
intensity was more for the tax and tax
cuts than it was for replacing and
repeated repealing and replacing
Obamacare and building
the border security while I think you're
right about that but there's some
intensity today we've been pushing and
like I said we just passed a bill that
puts 5 billion dollars for a border
security wall and that is a good first
step
amen to that car thanks very much for
coming on for that update no bad checker